it's everybody I'm Calvin tang I'm the
CDC a twin son in Brooklyn New York and
I'm back here at BuzzFeed the last time
I was here and go challenged me to
create a dessert and an entree with
ingredients from Daiso and this time I'm
cooking with ingredients from 7-eleven
from Taiwan I didn't fly to Taiwan but
Inga was there recently and she brought
back some stuff for me to work with
let's see what you brought back I was
looking at heavy this is like your whole
suitcase damn know I can't even read
Chinese so I don't even know what the
half of this stuff is until I open it
and taste it this is mad stuff so I'm
gonna try to sort this out into two
different piles to kind of see what I
have to work with for an entree and a
dessert reserved duck eggs salted duck
eggs did you actually try to bring it
smart don't travel with eggs will
Sakurai's it's fair sea salt latte
interesting chicken corn soup some more
corn I expected the snacks not freakin
duck eggs voice your sauce nice this is
the brand I like to cool entree dessert
I'm definitely gonna use this rice
filling the rice is so versatile you do
so many different things with it I'm
probably gonna do a soup just cuz this
is in English and I can read it that's
chicken corn soup which is weird because
I'm used to seeing soup in a can not
like a four ounce packed thing let's
open this up check it out
yeah it's literally just like cup
noodles without the noodles I just
retired with hot water and that's it I'm
curious to see what this snack tastes
like those imma bust these open this one
looks cool what's up with the beer on it
it works well with beer I guess oh he's
really good definitely use that clue
potato chips a little vegetable to the
soup super crunchy a little sweet you
like big on corn soup this corn soup
flavored looks like shrimp chips but it
was like popcorn in here
this is my breakfast I actually didn't
eat today so this good way to start more
corn
all right so we're gonna definitely do
something with corn it's like five
different corn things like pudding oh so
like like blood I don't know about this
one
cause he came and tell you what that
tastes like
citrusy which is weird yeah we could
work with this dessert I'm probably just
gonna do some chocolate mousse situation
since we have marshmallows and I know
marshmallows contain gelatin and so that
should help set and bring it all
together
lastly not a big dessert guy I don't
really like sweets um let's hope this
like works out so I'm gonna start with
dessert first just cuz I know I need to
let the mousse set and then while that
setting we can work on the entree first
I'm probably gonna take some of these
marshmallows melt them down with a
couple different chocolates the English
at me wonder if these are flavored a
little bit choose them one peg should do
a little oil helps it get started
but if you're at home and you have
butter definitely use butter or not oil
don't know what this is
you've had this before kind of salty
tonight all right I'll save that for the
cross don't waste it for the inside the
Oreos in that in this bootleg Pocky
stick for the crust milk chocolate it's
an English or the only thing scare ya
know where well dump it in
I'm definitely gonna throw this kinder
in just because I really like
kindergarten
if you're at home you have milk feel
free to use some milk but we have this
latte sea salt latte mix I'm gonna sue
me will contain lots of milk I'm just
trying to see how much water it
recommends using for a packet but once
again nothing's in English no leaders I
don't know what that is either
it I'm just gonna throw this in and
taste it and adjust from there there are
plenty of packets if it needs more
plenty of water it needs more plenty of
everything
I sure afraid this won't set for the
evolution of us
it smells really good you smell it I'm
just trying to melt it all make it all
like one mixture
it's not looking too hot why not set I
might need some heavy cream yeah can I
cheat with one thing this time it's all
melted now so I'm just gonna pour this
into a stainless steel bowl throw it in
the freezer and let it hang out for a
bit
hopefully it'll set a little bit more
once the jealous and cools and then I
whip up the cream and fold that in later
wait I don't even taste it
I see things like a lot there is this
sea salt latte so I'm gonna roll with
that and add a little more salt 7-eleven
is definitely sells salt and oil in
Taiwan so it's not cheating yeah way
better
cool so while the mousse filling is
cooling I'm just gonna work on the
entree I'm definitely thinking about
doing like a bootleg porridge congee
chicken corn soup with the eggs some of
the stuff for garnish and if we go rice
in it to bulk it up see how this works
more powdered product all the stuff is
that plate for convenience and super
easy if you're just buying this all I
got to do is put hot water into it and
you have a meal basically but we're
gonna jazz that up today yeah I have no
idea how much water so again it's gonna
wing it and taste it this smells really
good it smells like the strip just
smells like a sweet cheese doodle and
these three came out that's other square
box it just looks like cornmeal ooh you
know moto so it has to be good they make
msg so everything they make is delicious
dude a corn MSG salt it's gonna be great
all right I'm gonna dump this into
another I'll save one to adjust the
seasoning later start this you just
whisk it up and all that powder dissolve
we just cranked it on high let it rock
who's gonna add my rice now who's gonna
flip at oh forgot we have like actually
fresh corn kernels whoo
it comes like a little spoon as you're
getting this in your lunchbox it's
busting out of candy corn for lunch
it's kind of tight yummy isn't dumping
the eggs I'm probably gonna throw them
in last second these guys don't need to
cook if you ever had this before it's
kind of funky duck eggs that might just
say if it's a good garnish and he's
great on top I'll crack this open now
typically eaten with congee so it's not
even that weird straight up feels like a
rubber ball I like to do this on the
floor like bounce right back do one more
it's a big pot of soup I literally used
to eat this all the time it's just like
a snack and eat it with pickles yeah
over you kid all right slice these guys
up it's hard to find like a sleeve
they're gonna for this thing so I took
old shoe box and I change it out like
every month and it's free where's your
wedge these guys oh yeah super sulfurous
I don't know why someone would like this
but I like it actually I'll cut into 12
it's a little intense to get a big bite
put that aside keep checking on this guy
just whisk it up so the rice doesn't get
sports or stick to the bottom that's
really yeah like carrots a lot of corn
not bad huh good way to like clean out
your fridge if you're at home throw
everything in it that's about to go bad
it'll taste great so I'm probably just I
save the snacks for garnish it'd be a
waste to throw it in and just let it get
soggy so I'll put that on top or
something with this hanging out and then
we could whip the cream you're small
about
[Music]
as the one to get stuck I like the
elbows tucked in to the rib and a little
more wrist this is so tiring it smells
really good since we have creamy ready I
might just add a little splash of cream
in here as well just since we don't have
butter you don't need it but it's nice
to have it's like a lot of things in
life all right yeah I'm happy with this
it looks a little stiff peaks just pop
the whole thing in the fridge the soup
rice situation is looking pretty nice
it's getting thicker it smells really
good in the meantime I'm gonna check out
these duck eggs it's fully cooked as
well don't do anything to it I love
preserved duck eggs super salty
sometimes I would just eat this steamed
with like rice the yoke should be bright
orange yeah not the prettiest looking
things but they're tasty I might just
use the yolks and just crumble them on
top dad to call their richness and the
whites will fold into the soup yeah it's
getting super thick now I purposely
didn't wash the rice so it would be
extra starchy help thicken it up keep
cooking it water will keep reducing
slavery will concentrate should be good
since we just like winging this whole
thing you could kind of just adjust so
however you like it but I'm gonna taste
it now it's pretty ready corny but very
planned there's gonna douse this with
some oyster sauce not too much cuz I
don't want the color to change I think
it's a really cool yellow right now and
it'll finish it the rest with some salt
it's like
Asian corn chowder it's pretty good I'm
gonna cut the heat now hit it with the
cream at the end I like the consistency
it's at I looking for richness light in
the color a little bit these guys I'm
just gonna throw in breaking up with a
whisk a little salty bites are nice
preserved eggs right in okay final taste
I think we're good yeah I'm pretty happy
with it right now it's not like fully
fully season but I know all this stuff
is super salty so it will be good now
we're gonna go into the desert and
finish that up and then we could plate
the chocolate stuff set up pretty nice
honestly we don't need the cream but
took 20 minutes beating it I'm gonna use
it and fold it and make it a little
lighter I'm definitely gonna taste it
again now cuz things taste different
when they're hot and when they're cold
yeah that's good you could taste the
salt it's nice just do a little by
little and add more necessary since we
beat all the air into it we just want to
fold using a spatula that's good
I don't want it to be overly sweet right
now and it's I think it's perfect now
we're pretty much ready to plate I'm
just gonna check out these Oreos see
what we could do with them maybe layer
them
I found these sick little glasses in the
back I think it's fun to use like a
little tacky Cubs versus like a bowl
oh it's not having Oreos they're cream
O's damn that's good
stingy on the filling though the lemon
could be nice citrus and chocolate work
well together so I guess we could use a
little bit I might just chop this up mix
it with some other stuff cream puffs
looking mmm all right I know what I'm
doing I like this a lot
I'm like bury this in the middle like a
little surprise okay take your mousse
not too fine you wanna have some texture
so you just start building it
[Music]
little surprise whoa Fred the Pocky
stick either probably humongous yeah
Little Dipper
all right the search are done what if we
go in finishing the entree they got a
huge bowl here so it's gonna served
family-style yeah your vegetables your
eggs the proteins enough for like a
family of five little white B now I got
all these chips that we use for more
texture flavor and what's nice about
like a thick chowder or soup like this
everything you put on top will kind of
stay on top like croutons but better
little popcorn guys little popcorn
surprises in this one stick use up a
little bit for some height well I forgot
the egg yolks crumble a couple these
guys throughout we got a little more
than extra powder mix it we melt on the
side before it's right over the top
since it was even too salty
yeah and cool this there it is Asian
corn chowder thing we used everything
[Music]
Kelvin this was amazing I was a little
skeptical when you started throwing all
the chips on but it looks really good
I just love chips so you like three
separate bites to kind of hit all the
ingredients so it's a good night
[Music]
one chowder yeah it's a really nice
texture yeah it's like congee with the
dough stick Wow pop rocks a little it's
full of surprises oh I got the lemon in
the Oreo this tastes so good it's like
classic job Calvin thank I know once
again today was fun and went better than
I expected honestly you guys want me to
do another store another challenge next
time just let us know when we should hit
up Oh
[Music]